no Spanky treats the things he loves
with moderate aggression no shade to you
but commitment to me sounds a lot like
being institutionalized committed and
just the idea of like being with someone
for a really long period of time or like
for life it's kind of like nerve-racking
at my heart one slow but like it's just
too hard I don't think anybody is truly
ready for anything and this work holds
we just get handed things and we go with
it so I think there's no real perfect
time to foster a dog it's just you have
to be loving and you'll have to be
committed it's so cute isn't to shoot
okay guys I brought home a dog
[Music]
bring the key you can't open it
I'll give it to you out of the bag it's
a bag do it he's already managed to rip
my jeans but luckily he's cute so I
don't mind too much right this is a
white carpet I'm trying to just go okay
first night sweet day - I'm adventures
with Emmett I think he's come to like be
good move it back soon come on I have to
get to work spank spank around what's
wrong
and it will stop jumping we don't want
to eat I think he might be able to jump
out he is still very awake I don't know
if I walked him enough fetching fetch a
friend's house he keeps quiet and
everybody says not to feed into it but
it's not easy this really on a Sunday
now he's gonna take a food that's what
he does finding a better spot yep there
we go
so this is our morning routine now
someone wakes up very early and he's
super energetic and likes to bite
everything
then he tires himself out and then he
goes asleep it's still not a morning
person
I started to learn to give him a treat
and make him sit down
and then leave and that usually worked
because when I would throw the ball he
would like fake me out and then run out
the door all right
turns out bribery works wonders wonders
got him to like come up and down stairs
like the trees definitely having a dog
has made me wanna have something a
little bit more stable and kind of
commit to something longer because now
I've seen like the benefits of when you
like put the time into taking care of
something and like nurturing that kind
of just makes you want to love more it's
nice to have to care about someone else
there's this little thing with giant
eyes that like needs you to feed it I
think it puts a lot of stuff in
perspective try to like open yourself up
to like loving something you know like
open yourself up to actually truly
feeling love for something else he's
taught me about their responsibility of
taking care of someone this dog came at
a very good time I would have so many
more nights if it wasn't for him that I
was just sad or stressed out once you
become a foster and you realize that you
have this special connection with this
soulful helpless animal that was not
gonna make it if it wasn't for you
I think fostering an animal is one of
the things that makes you realize that
you have so much more love to give that
you thought before